it is day two of being back in the
classroom for about twenty thousand ccsd
students
a big transition few minor issues as
staff and students
adjust kristin drummond is live in our
newsroom with the latest update for
those heading back to class kristen
well brian as with any major adjustment
there are a few
issues and in this case it involves
technology
there's definitely families that are
feeling that
change rebecca garcia monitors the
transition to hybrid learning even with
the best intentions of trying to have
all the streaming
processes and cameras set up and things
like that that there were some
challenges with how to get onto this
google me
the nevada parent teacher association
president is also an administrator of
the ccsd parents page on facebook
there's a very active space where you
hear a lot from parents and teachers
about what's going right
and also what the challenges are the
most recent posts reflect a similar
message
about the transition to in-person
learning for some pre-kindergarten to
third grade students
compared to the first day of distance
learning in august
we heard a lot more positive feedback
yesterday it went great actually
ari o'brien noticing her second grade
daughter adjusting to the changes
at gerheim elementary school that
includes social distancing and
working on the computer while in class
they did
some online the teacher had some
students on virtually
so she was trying to incorporate both
classes many educators are now teaching
in person and online at the same time
minor issues you know
in reconnecting with students bringing
their devices back
on campus all which were fixable gerheim
elementary principal ryan lewis says he
and his staff remain flexible during
this time realistically
we were very pleased with how we were
prepared so we're really going to kind
of maintain what our protocols are for
cohort b coming a couple unions
mentioned
staff having trouble logging into the
emoka health program
that's the platform that allows staff to
monitor their daily symptoms
which is a district requirement i
reached out to ccsd and was told
they're working on my request reporting
live in the newsroom kristen drummond 8
news now